we as developers love serverless we love
that we can focus on code deploy and let
the platform take care of the rest but
we also keep asking what else can we
deploy on serverless what about going
beyond simple functions well you can
today with cloud run which lets you run
any stateless container on server list
with cloud run you can forget about
infrastructure
it focuses on fast automatic scaling
that's request aware so you can scale
down to zero and only pay when it's
being used to demo this I'm going to
deploy a serverless micro service that
transforms Word documents to PDFs to
perform this transformation does anyone
remember OpenOffice I'm going to simply
add OpenOffice inside a container and
then run it in a server list environment
let's see how easy it is to run it in a
container on cloud run from the console
go to cloud run and open the deployment
page select or paste the URL of the
container image and click create that's
all we needed to create a server list
container no infrastructure to provision
and advanced no yeah Mel file and no
servers cloud ron has imported my image
made sure that it started and gathered a
stable and secure HTTP endpoint what we
just deployed is a scalable and micro
service that transforms a document into
a PDF let's see in action let's give it
a doc to convert
and we get a PDF back OpenOffice is not
exactly a modern piece of software it's
about a 15 year old binary and it's
about 200 megabytes and we just took
that binary and deployed it as a service
workload with God run because cloud runs
supports docker containers that means
you can run any programming language you
want or any software in a server this
way let's look at the code we have a
small piece of Python code that listens
for incoming HTTP requests and calls
OpenOffice to convert our document we
also have a very small docker file it
starts by defining our base image in our
case it's the official Python based
image later we installed open office and
we specified our start command then we
packaged all of this into a container
image using cloud build and deployed it
to cloud run on cloud run our micro
service can automatically be scaled to
thousands of containers or instances in
just a few seconds we just took a legacy
app and deployed it to a macro service
environment without any change in code
but sometimes you might want to have a
little bit more control for example
bigger cpu sizes access to GPUs or
memory or maybe have it running on a
kubernetes engine cluster with cloud run
on gke it uses the exact same interface
I'm going to deploy the exact same
container image this time in gke and
instead of a fully managed region I'm
now picking our gke cluster we get the
same cloud run developer experience
it's deploying and our micro service is
creating as before we get a stable and
secure endpoint that automatically
scales our micro service
behind-the-scenes cloud run and cloud
run on gke are powered by K native an
open source project to run serverless
workloads that we launched last year
this means we can actually deploy the
exact same micro service to any
kubernetes cluster running on K native
let's take a look I exported the micro
service into a file service yamo then
using the cube see tail command I'll
deploy it to manage K native on another
cloud provider I'll enter keep CTL get K
service to retrieve the URL endpoint and
voila we have it now on another cloud
provider let's look into the service
that's running by entering G cloud beta
friend services described PDF service if
you're familiar with kubernetes these
api version and kind fields may look
familiar in this case we're not using
kubernetes but since cloud run
implements the Kay native API and
extension of kubernetes this is an API
object that looks like Qamar Nettie's k
native enables services to be run
portably between environments without
vendor locking cloud run gives you
everything you love about serverless
there are no servers to manage you get
to say in the code and there's fast
scale-up and more importantly scaled
down to zero you get to pay nothing when
there are no cycles being run use any
binary or language because it's on the
flexibility of containers it gives you
access to the Google cloud ecosystem and
ap is and you get a consistent
experience wherever you want it in a
fully managed environment or on gke
thanks for watching check out more in
the description below and subscribe to
stay up to date with the latest in
surplice on google cloud
[Applause]
[Music]